OK, now that we've gone over all of the different things that we need to get the system working,
as well as some of the prep work and things to consider before jumping into the engine,
let's start to create some of the assets that we'll need to utilise in the vehicle's
blueprint.
Now, we'll create two things first.
We'll create the wheel blueprints for each type of wheel on our vehicle, so there'll
be a front wheel and a rear wheel, and we'll create the curve asset that represents
the torque curve of our vehicle's engine.
So those two things.
But first, let's kick off with the wheel blueprints.
So the wheel blueprint does a lot of the heavy lifting when it comes to the initial setup
of the handling of the vehicle, and where you'll configure the settings for the wheels,
the suspension and the brakes to ensure that things operate correctly.
And you've got control over the setting of the wheel radius, the mass, the width,
the handbrake effect, suspension, and many other properties to give your vehicle the
handling that you desire.
With a four-wheeled vehicle, you typically need two different types of wheel blueprints.
So one for the front wheels and one for the rear wheels.
And you're setting up things like which ones are affected by the steering, which
ones are affected by the engine and the handbrake and which ones aren't.
And because there's no limit to the number of wheels that a vehicle can have, that
means that you can have as many wheel blueprints as you need, depending on the needs
of your vehicle.
And because the wheel blueprints are assets within the engine, and they're not just a
setting within the vehicle blueprint itself, you can actually share them across all of
the different vehicle blueprints in your project.
That is, if they share the same wheel dimensions and suspension limits, and essentially
a lot of the same settings that you can configure within the wheel blueprint.
So it's about time we jumped into the engine and started creating the assets that we need
for our Chaos Physics vehicle.
But first, before we start creating any of these assets, we need to make sure that the
plugin is enabled.
So if you come up to edit on the top left here, down to plugins, this will open up your
plugins window.
And in the search box, if we look for chaos vehicles, here we go, we have a few options.
There's the modular vehicles that we talked about and compared in the slides a little
earlier on.
But the one we're going to look at today is a chaos vehicles plugin, the standard
chaos vehicles plugin.
So make sure you check this box, you should get a little option down here that says
restart, and that'll just reload your project.
And when it opens up again, the plugin will be loaded and ready to use.
Now that the plugin is active, you know, we know that the system is online.
Let's start by making our wheel blueprints.
So we're going to need to make a wheel blueprint for the front wheels, and one
for the rear wheels.
So inside our content browser here, I'm just going to go into the vehicles folder and
create a new folder.
And I'll just call this blueprints.
And inside here, I'm pretty much going to build everything that we're going to need
to piece together to make this chaos vehicle of ours.
So I'm going to right click inside the content browser and choose blueprint class.
And we come to the old classes drop down here.
If this isn't open, you can just hit the little chevron to open it up.
And I'm going to search for wheel and then choose chaos vehicle wheel as our parent
class.
And I'm going to call this BP underscore wheel underscore front, because this is going to
be the settings for the front wheel.
And inside here, you've got all of the different properties you can configure for
the wheel and for the suspension and for the brakes down here.
And now you can set this up the axle type, whether it's front or rear, you can set
the wheel width and radius and mass settings and any sort of coring stiffness and friction.
So there's a lot you can do here with your initial setup to tweak sort of how the vehicle
performs and handles, which we'll take a look at a little later on in the in the course,
to give you like a little kickoff point for tweaking the settings for your own vehicles.
But for now, there are six properties that we want to change, depending whether it's
the front or the back wheel and whether or not we want it to be affected by the engine
or the brakes or the steering.
So let's take a look at that now.
So under the axle type, because we're working with the front wheel, we're going to set
this to front.
And we're going to set our wheel radius.
Now, we've measured as previously, we know that it's 35.
But if you remember from the slides a few moments ago, like is a great idea to just
get the radius of your wheel or the diameter and then half it to figure out the setting
that you would need here.
And then we need to figure out is this affected by the handbrake, which we're going
to say no, because this is the front wheel.
Is it affected by the engine?
Again, no.
And is it affected by steering?
And in this case, yes.
And we're also going to tweak the max steering angle, because we find that 45 works pretty
well for this vehicle mesh that we have.
And just come back to our content browser here.
What I'm going to do for the rear wheel is just highlight the front wheel, press
Ctrl D to duplicate it and rename it rear.
And if I open that up, we just need to tweak some of the settings again.
So the axle type this time is going to be rear, our wheel radius is the same.
We do want it affected by the handbrake.
And we do want it affected by the engine.
But this time, we don't want it to be affected by the steering.
So if I compile and save that again, that's just finished with the first couple of
assets that we're going to need to begin our chaos vehicle system.
Now the second asset that we need to configure for the system is a curve asset.
And this will represent the engine's torque curve.
Now as you know, this torque curve represents the amount of torque output in
Newton meters from the engine at a given RPM.
And this will be used to drive the acceleration of our vehicle.
Right clicking inside our content browser, we'll come up to a miscellaneous here,
and then choose curve.
And the class of curves that we want is a curve float.
And I'm just going to call that torque curve.
If I double click that to open it up, just dock it in here again,
you can see we get this graph with two axes, a vertical axis and a horizontal axis.
And this is where we're going to create our curve.
So the first thing that we want to do is you can see just as my mouse hovers
over the zero line on the horizontal axis, you can see that everything sort
of highlights.
And this is where our curve is right now, essentially, except we don't have any
keys on there to make it look any different than just a flat line.
So anywhere along this curve, I'm just going to middle mouse click twice,
once on the left, once on the right.
And these are just going to represent the minimum and the maximum of our
engine's RPM.
So on the left hand side here, I'm going to set the horizontal axis to
zero, and the vertical axis to 0.5.
And on the right hand side, we're going to set the horizontal axis to 5,000
because that'll be our max RPM, and the vertical axis to 0.5.
And if I just click inside the graph anywhere in an empty space and press
this button here, or press F on the keyboard, what that's going to do is
zoom out so that we can see all of the keys on our curve.
Now, this is the beginning of our curve, but again, it's still very flat.
So I'm just going to add two more keys.
And for this first key, we'll set at 1,000 RPM.
We want that to hit 100% of our torque value.
And over here at 4,000 RPM, we want it to drop down to roughly 0.8,
so about 80% of our torque value.
So you'll notice that I haven't put the torque right up to any sort of crazy
number because the value is actually normalized between zero and one.
So one will essentially just give you whatever your maximum torque setting
is at this RPM.
So we don't actually put the torque values in here.
They go into the vehicle's blueprint itself.
But that's all we need to do to get our torque curve set up.
This can be as complex or as simple as you'd like it to be.
You can also smooth off these curves here by changing the key type
that you have here.
So you could right click, change it to any of these different sort
of key types.
So you could say auto and sort of smooth out all of these.
You've also got the options across the top of the bar here, the toolbar
just up here.
But for now, we're going to just keep them all as linear.
And if I save that and close it, we need to take a look at just one
more asset before beginning to connect things up into our main vehicle
blueprint.
And that is the vehicle's physics asset, now namely the one that was generated
when we imported the skeletal mesh.
Now, the collision bodies inside the physics asset get set up and generated
automatically on import to the system's best guess, basically, as long
as you have the option checked.
Now, we want to delete all of this hard work that the engine's done for
us and set them up manually.
But we're just going to add physics bodies for the bones that we need so
that we know it's going to work properly with the system that we're
trying to create.
So having said all that, if we find our existing physics asset, so come
back to the vehicles folder here, into CSSUV and inside meshes, there's
our skeletal mesh and our paired physics asset.
If I double click to open this up, now when we open the physics asset,
it's going to look something like this, where it's made its best guess
at generating essentially all the collision bodies for all of the joints
that are skinned in the skeletal mesh.
But we don't really want any of these here because they're not the
right shape, they're not the right size.
There's too many of them for what we need.
So I'm just going to highlight them all and press delete.
And then inside the skeleton tree here, I'm going to choose show
weighted bones, and this will just show us the bones that have
meshes weighted to them.
And really what we're looking for ideally is the four wheel bones and
the root.
So we have the root here and we have the wheel rear and the wheel front.
So first of all, for the root with the root highlighted, I'm going
to come over to the tools panel just on the right hand side here
and change the primitive type to be a box.
And I'm going to untick orient, auto orient to bone, just so that
when I hit add bodies now, we essentially just get a world
aligned box that covers the entire sort of main body of the
mesh here.
And really, I'm just going to leave that as it is.
And then for all of the wheels, if I highlight each of those,
I'll turn back on orient to bone.
And I'm going to change the primitive type to a sphere.
And again, add bodies.
What this does is it orients this sphere to the bone.
And it does its best guess of encapsulating that mesh that is
skinned to this bone within the physics body itself.
And it's done a pretty good job at that straight away.
And that's the main bulk of what we need to do to generate
the physics bodies for this mesh.
But now we need to just tweak some of the physics types
and collision responses of the physics bodies for the
wheels specifically, so that they react properly
for our system.
So if I select our wheel physics bodies here in the
skeleton tree, and then come over to the details panel,
I'll set the physics type to be kinematic.
And all this does is make sure that the wheels are
affected by the vehicle's bounds and shadows and
culling occur correctly.
And if I scroll a little further down,
we can change the collision response to disabled,
which means they have no collision on them.
And that's just because these won't be used for
collision for our vehicle.
And instead the wheels use ray casting to interact with
the world.
Now we have our wheel blueprints.
We have our torque curve, and we've updated the collision
bodies in our physics asset.
The final thing that we need to set up before we connect
all of these things together is the animation blueprint.
Now this is what we use to control skeletal mesh
animations, typically an animation blueprint.
So for us, that would be things like the tires spinning,
the suspension, the steering animations.
Now, normally you would create these animations sort of in
external software or inside the engine itself,
and then set up the logic to determine, you know,
when these animations should play based on things like the
skeletal meshes speed or direction,
or if they're on or off the ground, these kinds of things.
But something super useful in the chaos vehicle system is
a single node that can get all of the information about
the car's current state from the wheels.
Things like how fast are they spinning or what are the
suspension settings for this wheel?
And then translate this information into bone animation
for each of the associated wheels.
Now, this means that it will be creating the bone
animations at runtime without the need for us to set up
any sort of complex logic or author any animations for
when this car is driving around.
And this node is the wheel controller.
And it essentially queries information about the wheel,
and then translates that into skeletal animation for the
vehicle, saving us from creating animations and setting up
a lot of complex logic.
So back inside the engine,
let's set up the animation blueprint.
If I right click,
come up to animation and choose animation blueprint,
we choose what skeleton we want to affect.
So that's our vehicle skeleton that we have here.
And I'm going to choose a parent class.
And this is going to be the vehicle animation instance.
And if I rename our animation blueprint here
to ABP chaos vehicle,
I'll just double click that to open up.
And inside here,
we're only going to need a few nodes really
that we're working with.
So if I right click and search for the wheel controller
for wheeled vehicle node,
that was the one we just looked at,
and connect that straight up to our output pose.
Now this gives us a new node,
a component to local mode,
which essentially converts all of the translation information
from component to local space,
because the wheel controller runs in component space.
And the last thing we're going to need
is a mesh space ref pose.
And I can create that by either dragging off
the input pose or the wheel controller,
or just right clicking and then searching for it
and connecting the logical.
And what this essentially does is grabs our meshes
default pose,
or what would be like a T pose for the character
and says, hey, this is your starting point
and for the wheel control to make its calculations
from for the different transforms for the wheels.
So we're grabbing our default pose.
Then we're grabbing the information about the wheels,
converting that from component space to local space
and connecting that to our output pose.
And that's all we need to do
to set up the animation blueprint.